everybody is playing their 20s backwards
if you guys understood that you could
accomplish nothing for the next eight
years and I mean zero and still be young
as [__] and like dominate life you would
get on a plane and spend the next two
years going everywhere because there's
no downside and there's nothing but
upside everybody's got such a chip on
their shoulder between debt or to prove
to somebody that they've got something
that they go right into dumb [__] to
start getting short money and like do
the right thing or prove something they
need to punt the 22 to 30 year old
should be even more ridiculous than 18
to 22. I think people should [__]
punt it I think you guys should [__]
go around the world as a horde live in
shitty places like learn taste play